- I'd rather have someone poop all over me
or have my kid poop on an airplane
or have my kid pee on
my head or poop my pants
than be covered in dead whale.
I can say that definitively.
- That's a really remarkable observation.
(pleasant electronic music)
- When I was 13, my family took a cruise,
and at one of the ports, my
parents thought it would be
a good idea to take the
bus to one of the further,
less populated beaches to spend the day.
So far, so good.
- Okay, okay.
- Lo and behold, it was a nude beach.
Now it's getting really good!
- (gasps) She was 13?
- Mm-hmm, it was my,
- Oh dear!
- Her parents are in
jail by now aren't they?
- First time seeing a man naked.
That can be startling,
'cause it's also like
you've got an extremity
we don't know about.
You know what, can I pause
this story for one second?
We were on a Fourth of July
trip with another family,
and all of us have girls
except one of our friends has
a boy, and his name is Ace,
and Ace likes to be nude
and he's three and a half.
- My kids do, too.
- Of course, everyone, and
everyone else is a girl,
and his mom said, Ace,
okay, it's five o'clock.
Can you just at least
put some underwear on,
and he goes why, no, why?
And she goes, well, I don't know,
because everyone else is a girl
and just put some
underwear on, and he goes,
oh, because I have a penis
and they just have butts?
(Kelsey chuckles)
My parents didn't want to waste the day
trying to find a different
beach, efficient.
They told my brothers and I
to look at the ocean only.
Of course, being 13 years old and curious,
I couldn't help but look
at the old man walking along the beach.
I asked my parents why
the men were wearing
their wedding rings around their penises.
That was the start of their discussion
of (beep) rings with my brother and I.
I will never forget that day
and that discussion.
- That is a nightmare!
(Kelsey chuckles)
- Well, or it's just a
way to express yourself.
I mean, I'm wearing rings
and earrings.
- Do people wear
- (beep) rings at nude beaches?
- If you're gonna go to a nude beach,
why couldn't you wear a piece of jewelry.
- Around, yeah.
- Around your ding dong.
- My brother had just
turned one when we went
to Disney World for the
first time and I was 10.
I was sitting on the plane beside my mom,
and my brother started screaming.
We thought it was because
his ears were popping,
but it turned out that he
had the worst diarrhea ever.
- Ooh!
- It was everywhere.
- Uh-oh!
- On the seat, on my mom, on my brother.
The flight attendant brought us club soda
to, quote, unquote, "fix the problem"
and a garbage bag and paper towels.
They wouldn't let my mom get up
because the seatbelt light wasn't off yet.
She made holes in the garbage bag
and tied it at his waist, sat
him on her lap, and waited.
- Diarrhea is rough in general.
- This poor kid, though.
- Let alone on a plane.
- It must've smelled terrible.
- It's the other passengers
that I think really got the
(beep) end of the deal, pun intended.
My husband and I were on our honeymoon.
I was on medication that made stuff happen
a lot faster than you'd hope.
We were two blocks from our rental flat
when I told my husband that
I had to go, capital, NOW.
We walked home on icy sidewalks
as quickly as my butt allowed.
As soon as we unlocked
the front door, I felt it.
I did everything I could to clench,
but it came forth like
an explosion of hot lava.
I crunched down saying, it's
happening, it's happening
like I was in Bridesmaids.
We got up and I finished in the bathroom
as my amazing husband cleaned
up my pants with his hands.
It definitely wasn't how we
expected our honeymoon to go,
but you can't deny that that's love.
That's a beautiful story,
that's not a horror story.
- I went on a cruise with my grandma,
and she tried to scatter
my great-grandpa's ashes
off the back of the boat.
I ended up rinsing my grandpa
off about four levels of the
ship with a cup of water.
When my great-grandma died
and we wanted to scatter
her ashes in the same way,
my grandma hollowed out bread rolls
and put the ashes inside to
prevent a repeat of events.
All right, okay, Hot
dog buns off the back--
- Is your grandmother MacGyver?
That's genius!
(Kelsey chuckling)
My family and I were
on a vacation in Egypt.
I felt sick all day, so as
soon as we got to the tombs,
I ran into the bathroom,
bypassing the lady who was
handing out the toilet paper.
I rushed into the stall as my
ass exploded on the toilet.
I kept yelling for my sister
to get me toilet paper,
but apparently, you have to pay
for each square in public restrooms there.
She ended up spending $4 on toilet paper.
Two hours later, after
we finished our tour
and walked by the lobby,
I saw a Closed for Maintenance
sign on the toilet I used.
My ass literally broke an
Egyptian national monument.
That'll teach you to put some, you know,
tissue in your pocket.
- Well, travel.
- One Fourth of July weekend,
we got stuck in standstill
traffic and my youngest brother,
who was six at the time,
kept complaining that he had to pee.
Here we go again.
- Here we go.
- We couldn't pull over,
so my dad gave him a
Gatorade bottle to pee into.
My brother started peeing in the bottle
just as the traffic started
moving a little bit.
The sudden movement of
the car jolted my brother
from where he was
standing, it was a minivan,
and he dropped the bottle
but didn't stop peeing.
He literally peed all over
the side of my dad's head
and the steering wheel.
- My mum's side of the family
consists of about 20 Irish people,
and we often hire out hostels
to ourselves for the Christmas holidays.
One year, we stayed by the seaside,
and my uncle overheard in a local pub
that a dead whale had
washed up on the beach
and that someone was going to
blow it up and get rid of it.
Obviously, we wanted to see the spectacle.
When we finally arrived,
there were bits of dead whale everywhere
with the worst rotting smell
I have experienced to this day.
My mum decided to kick
a piece of whale blubber
that was lying around, which exploded
and splattered all over me.
I was 11 years old, covered
head to toe in dead whale.
That's rough.
- That is rough!
- That would be a hard one for me.
I'd rather have someone poop all over me
or have my kid poop on an airplane
or have my kid pee on
my head or poop my pants
than be covered in dead whale.
I can say that definitively.
- That's a really remarkable observation.
My family and I were
vacationing in the Caribbean,
and my sister ended up
stepping on sharp coral.
- Ouch!
- Well, this can be a difficulty.
To make it worse, there were
no hospitals in the area,
so two fishermen cut it out of her foot
while my parents held her screaming.
On our way to the car, my dad realized
he had locked the keys in the car.
We ended up having one of the
locals break into the car.
On the way back to the hotel,
a Category 2 hurricane hit
and demolished the island.
We got shelter in a coffee shop,
but not before I was
hit with a flying sign.
Needless to say, we have not
been back to the Caribbean.
(Kelsey chuckles)
- [Kristen] We were
able to film this movie.
There were two times in the hallway
where people just were like I'm out, pssh,
and we called 911 and got
them ambulances, yeah.
I'm gonna write that down
and send it into Buzzfeed.
- We were fine (laughs).
(whooshing electronic accents)